what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here and I'm John so we are filming
this on Christmas Eve John and I watch
super late last night Netflix is bright
right and we thought we'd do something a
little bit of a different type of video
here a while ago we did our reaction to
the Justice League early reactions
people seem to really like us going over
that and hearing their responses I
thought like you know we really loved
being on the start us at there's a lot
of people we follow over there so right
now we have this six minute cut of
Stardust reactions which we haven't seen
any of I'm new my minds included in here
but I haven't seen any ones I haven't
heard the Rotten Tomatoes consensus I
haven't heard but I haven't heard a
single review or opinion on the movie so
we thought we'd do reaction to
everyone's opinion on bright on the
Stardust app so we get a bunch of early
reaction responses and then we'd hop
into our non-spoiler review right right
afterwards and then on a separate video
we'll do a little spoiler talk because
my issues with the film I would have to
kind of talk about spoilers in order to
to really explain it why I don't give it
a full recommendation anyway let's check
out these earlier reactions so I just
got done watching bright on a late
Saturday night I thought it was a pretty
cool film actually I really liked the
world pretty sweet Will Smith was cool
so tired but overall I'd say that I
enjoyed a solid 89% of it was a lot
better than I expected it to be Joel
Edgerton was gray there's some but I
really enjoyed it but you'll know maybe
when you watch it do you recommend it
good one Netflix I like so many elements
of this movie
and the concept is fantastic there's
some good acting I like a lot of these
actors and stuff but ultimately the
movie is just okay you know it's just
not great it's not terrible but I really
was hoping for more out of everything
that we had in this movie ultimately I
would watch a sequel you know if they
fully capitalized on the potential but
that's just this one didn't
unfortunately so I saw Brian a couple
days ago and I mean it's crazy and
creative like max landis does Dave I
think bright is a badass film and for
seeing it for free on Netflix is worth a
try now just finished bright with Will
Smith on Netflix
it was really good I thought looking guy
right it's really taken to it but really
I didn't know that the original
storyline it was really good it was a
bit slow going towards the end but other
than that and I can really see a sequel
coming along yes oh you haven't given a
watch we just finished watching Netflix
original break that just came out to be
one will submit right enjoy as a sense
playing the port okay so or police
officer and a regular african-american
human police office the race is not a
thing of color anymore as the actual we
think of species okay no me Rapace from
the girl with the dragon says lewis and
it was already know we enjoyed it you
shall watch a great movie it's okay it's
a passable film I think there are some
enjoyable things you can get intended
great jobs you know as their parts
script I could tell you it's bad I think
what worked out
it's a excuse we're look it's late and I
haven't slept so I am sleepy but I
wanted to give my review a bite yeah
it's a disappointment the dialogue is
pretty terrible in this may be my kid
just off there's 70 things wrong but
yeah I didn't like it no good some good
beds but no good rb3 Kuchar now it looks
like there and this movie gives it to me
but it gives you that old buddy when
they play off each other it's really
good thanks filming bright Netflix has
been killing it with your movies this
year and this one's pretty good one I
don't know created so much really I had
no idea some of the negatives Oh
anything I had no idea that repetitive
in the middle if you like and some of
the writing wasn't that great so the
jokes alien for me but others and then I
had a really fun time with in the action
was cool the world-building was cool and
yeah I'm excited for a sequel because
I'm never gonna do one so yeah Will
Smith I'm bored I really enjoyed this
film
Smith was fantastic as usual and joel
edgerton did a really good job
especially with all that makeup on his
face
half an hour of world-building to get
you into this movie and at times I felt
a little like a TV film so Netflix is a
perfect place for this but if you're a
fantasy lover dungeon dragons lord of
the rings world of warcraft I definitely
recommend going and check this out if a
great director and good cast but just
now I'd say well it does have some green
moments that's a great ideas and had a
great flower wills been touched in the
film there's a girlfriend potentials
hoping the go is very buoyant and tough
things in your face and the villain wow
I'm so surprised by a lot of what we're
hearing is voiced I want to say about AI
give her one scene that's the end of
that oh man Wow
I had surprises there's a lot of people
saying that critics are bashing on this
I I had no idea tear I pull up my first
yeah because because a lot of this was
surprising to me I mean a lot of people
were feeling like it's it's kind of
boring at times people were saying it's
just okay yeah and some people were
disappointed by it and it's a lot of it
is opposite from how I feel about the
movie do I think it's perfect no not at
all I would say that there's plenty to
be had in this film that makes it
totally worthwhile one consistent thing
I was hearing in these opinions is the
world-building seems to be everyone's
favorite part like the world of it all
seems to be the coolest part of it and
and yet it is it is actually yeah yeah
before you go into the the main drive of
the story with all the big you know
prophecy stuff yeah just watching them
beat cops together what that situation
is all about what it's like it worked
for them yeah you know because this is
not a traditional right situation like
that stuff yeah I was really engrossed
by and I thought the writing really sang
during those parts totally it's kind of
hopping into I guess our opinion of it
our review of it I gave it a 4 out of 5
stars and I would stick with that I
would even mean despite hearing like a
lot of people are not feeling that way
about this movie like it three or three
and a half yeah I think three and a half
at least I would give it yeah
like I I admire stuff about this movie
especially in like the landscape of now
I'm like hey like it's an original
clothes it's cool to get a weird
original movie yeah and I think part of
the great effect of it is that it's hard
our rating and it feels like a comic
book it feels like a comic book and
doesn't need to feel like a comic book
but that if that feel does work for the
film it felt more like this is more what
David Ayer wanted to do with Suicide
Squad
I couldn't Lee making up for it I
couldn't help but feel that because like
Will Smith feels more like the Deadshot
we should have gotten David Ayer style
of the heart our and the grittiness of
LA mixed in with some fantasy elements
seems more along the lines of what David
Ayer wanted to do well in terms of the
more mystical elements and the magic
stuff I thought this movie struck a much
better balance at that than Suicide
Squad ever did because you know the
magical elements are totally mismatched
yeah movie was here there's pretty much
the right level I thought I think the
world of it is incredibly neat and I was
so surprised by how well he pulled it
off you know when I heard Will Smith
talk in that video where he was getting
interviewed by Conan at Comic Con he
specifically said it's like training day
meets Lord of the Rings when I was
watching this I was like oh it is it is
that he managed to blend both worlds in
a great great way that earns this film a
crap ton of points for me because that
is such a hard and difficult tone to
pull off to get the grittiness of LA
which David Ayer is so well known to do
yeah combine it with the fantasy element
of elves orcs fairies and I love the
concept of the world how everything
that's happened in a world has happened
but also there's orders like they talk
about the Alamo has happened you know so
I'm sure everything else has happened
too and then you have this world of orcs
who also live amongst us and very and
rich and the concept of Bright's of how
rights are these special beings that are
rare that can wield wands and wands can
do these incredible magical things it
was so neat to see and also to have like
the hard our dialogue made it cool
because if it wasn't hard our I think it
just would have felt incredibly cheesy
because I think you needed that
grittiness of all the f words
a type of raw dialogue above these
characters have with each other
this film touches a lot on racism I
thought it was so neat because you got
Will Smith in here as the lead actor and
he's an african-american leading actor
playing a cop and then the orcs they
kind of represent how black people are
usually portrayed in movies and TV shows
all kinds of races but there's specific
stuff where you're like okay the orcs
are kind of played more like the black
community in terms of not just real-life
around the world but in terms of how you
see them portrayed in LA and a lot of
movies especially like David a yeah I
mean those are yeah this sort of like go
to aesthetics for gangland gangland
especially in LA Latino the Mexican
community and the black community that
was fascinating to see and Will Smith I
thought killed it cuz I thought he was
just gonna be Will Smith you know like
charming guy kind of makes fun of people
sometimes but he did play a guy where at
times where he's kind of not likable
especially in the first half of this
movie the way how kids in this story
he's partnered up with an orc
played by Joel Edgerton the orcs name is
Nick I believe Cubans like essentially
don't like orcs because there was a war
that went on a lie thousands of years
ago so it's a play on like biblical
things you're upset over them over
something that happened 2,000 years ago
which is like such a Christian thing to
say and it also kind of draws from any
and all of your prior knowledge of
orcish and elfish yeah any of that
that's floating at the back of your mind
kind of support a foundation and seeing
Will Smith in an r-rated role with all
the swear words he's saying but also the
way how he's kind of mean to a lot of
people his situation just doesn't seem
like it's ever much good and you feel
that through his performance I mean he's
always dealing with stuff awful
co-workers and awful situations in an
awkward partner situation and and all
sorts of stuff the balance between joel
edgerton znik the orc character and and
Will Smith in this movie was great it's
the highlight in the heart of this film
is their partnership because it is kind
of like train day in the sense that Will
Smith is more of the veteran cop he's
not a crooked cop like Denzel was in
training day but he is more of the
veteran cop and he's a cop with a lot of
morals despite how he can be an [ __ ]
a lot of the times he's a good cop he's
realistic but yeah you know and it has
integrity yeah he has
integrity and then he's got this partner
who everyone seems to hate and the orc
community views Nick as a traitor to the
orc community because he's a cop the
Oracle I don't accept him yeah they're
like you know once an orc always noir
yeah you'll never really go against your
clan and it plays a lot on how there's
racism within the LAPD you have this orc
character who's hated by his own people
and hated by the people he wants to be
accepted by as well he's just this
really innocent good-hearted soul this
this orc character Edgerton plays him so
great so much sincerity in that
performance man he's so good yeah he
brings a lot to it he's able to turn in
a great performance through a pretty
great makeup - yeah yeah joel edgerton
really surprised me and just in the
characterization like the way he played
him because he's you know it's a little
different than you would expect an orc
cop to be in and in the first part of
this movie I mean this is breaking my
heart like yes guy can't catch a break
from no no no and you watch him tried to
show up and to be pleasant despite that
and yeah something about those
characters that always touches me
partnership is complicated and while
they're arc is predictable and where
their partnership will end up by the end
of this film there's some telegraphing
feature I wouldn't want it to go any
other way though okay well I can't wait
for their arc to get to that point you
know plays out in less cliche ways and I
imagine and it seemed very natural when
they got to that are the scenes they
have of dialogue when they're budding
heads more than just playful banter some
real dramatic moments it's so good the
thing is the last half of this movie it
becomes a little intermittent between
great and this is a little much and this
is just okay that's that's the problem I
think the first half is pretty solid
material
yeah the first half gripped me pretty
much the whole time the first half is
when it is more ground it's just
grounded and gritty yeah I love that
just sticking with LA and sticking with
the circumstances and sticking with the
responses to the situation's the problem
that occurs in this film is when it
becomes borderline finale Suicide Squad
territory where it starts getting bigger
than it needs to be there's this be
story wait a lot of movies work cuz you
have a be story that eventually becomes
like the main story and the B story in
here is the Dark Lord with the elves is
coming back to regain power over the
world they keep cutting back
to building up to this some big bad on
the on the horizon yeah and that I just
didn't I wasn't a fan of I thought it
was too much I mean a little bit here
and there having some of that mythology
that's cool there's some scenes where
there's just way too much focus on it
for me I didn't dislike any of the ideas
that they had I just thought that the
second half of the movie I wish would
have played it closer to the ground
closer to the realism of the world we
had another they went full-on Suicide
Squad but it does it gets you fearful
that they're going to yeah it kept
they're starting to become a pattern
where it would push me to a point where
I yeah then it would bring me back
usually but yeah there there are some
some parts in the middle where it starts
to meander some it gets kind of
repetitive in this movie they got all
kinds of people coming after them yeah I
got there the enemies of everyone yeah
gang keeps busting in with like their
machine guns and they're just spraying
notes and everything like those those
sequences started to be like okay I get
it I still thought it was fun like a
thousand of these people like are they
just gonna keep producing more and more
gangsters like I thought it was fun down
I thought it was cool and I like how you
know you would have the gangsters
talking about gang things and they would
also talk about wanting this wand that's
integral to to bettering their life well
yeah that was a moment that brought me
back with poison gives that speech of
like this is why I want that you're
gonna deprive me of that and I'm like
yeah the elves in this movie are pretty
cool too I loved how they handled it
because you know we've seen Lord of the
Rings where the elves are the ultimate
warriors and the enlightened ones you
know they're always a little stuck up it
seems but in this movie the elves are
kind of scary the elves in this movie
are not viewed as the good guys no they
just live in rich appa lists they relive
a good job drive Lamborghinis look down
a punch they kind of ruled the world and
they're all so lethal that they're scary
matter who you throw their way they'll
kill them yeah because they are lethal
warriors so I like that implementation
of taking you know how I'm like Lord of
the Rings we see the elves or the
coolest ones with fighting well what if
we put them in this world and they're
kind of greedy and they have all the
power they're also the most
warriors as well that was a cool element
to infuse in likewise with the aurochs
as well you know cuz joel edgerton is
just a good cop but every once in a
while is or extract and his sense of
smell really comes in handy they kept
that detail running cuz like early on in
the movie there were subtle moments was
he sniffing stuff and like they wouldn't
even always acknowledge it but yeah like
that sense of smell motif keeps coming
up the finale of the film that's where
my biggest issues coming because that's
when it gets way too heavily focused on
the big mythological stuff I mean
mythology stuff is is necessary to
acknowledge because you got a whole new
world here so you need to acknowledge it
but building up to big baddie and a lot
of it seems like sequel set up and
finale twist at the end a was an
annoying predictable thing that I really
wish didn't happen I didn't care for it
and it also it seemed like it was
convenient for the plot it takes
something out of that moment because you
know yeah I'm not gonna go to poorly and
you also have this cool element infused
in its world building of the feds
there's a section is the magic depart
yeah federal government who like comes
in when things really hit them but you
got this human character who seems
really authentic to this world in just
in real life like without all the elves
and stuff like yeah it seems like a
federal type of fat dude dude the beer
he just swears a lot he's really right
blunt then you got this elf character
who works with him who kind of reminded
me of an anime character and I thought
their setup and everything was really
neat and cool but by the end of the film
I realized they're very essential to the
plot they serve no purpose other than
build up for a sequel the big intrigue
and the thing that was most gripping
about it was the blend of real-life
gangster grittiness and la combined with
these fantasy creatures meshed in it's
when you get all big into the mythology
and then exploring that and making the
world even crazier and bigger in that
retrospect it's like think of suicide
skal when they go all crazy enchantress
by the end when they're building up that
kind of stuff you're like oh come on man
just cut we don't need that in this
installment we really don't need that
here yeah especially since they greenlit
the sequel
like the day before anyway but I will
say though Joel Edgerton and Will Smith
are great in it the world is really cool
I don't agree with a lot of people
saying the dialogues bad because I
thought the dialogue in the last half
has some intermittent parts that are off
but I feel like a lot of the dialogue
was cool I feel like there was a lot of
moments that actually had me laughing I
really respected the fact that they made
this original weird-ass movie that
seemed to work for most of it that's my
favorite part of this yeah because III
have issues with it for sure but I was
really I it pulled me in I really
enjoyed getting to know the world and I
enjoyed being along for the ride and
even if it did lose me or or push me at
certain points into wondering if it was
gonna become silly over like completely
silly it would often bring me back with
something but it doesn't there's enough
there to Treach that territory where
you're like yeah it flirts with it and
sometimes it yeah but it usually plays
it doesn't go full-on bonkers like
you're thinking in my day you know the
writing was a lot better than the first
half and then the more pieces started to
converge and the more heightened things
started to get I thought the dialogue
started losing its flavor
yeah after a while there are a lot of
scenes that are just a delivery system
scenes where people are asking very
obvious questions getting very obvious
answered again intermittent so sometimes
you know the writing and the great
moments between Will Smith and Joel
Edgerton would come back they are the
heart and soul yeah because it doesn't
just stop being like having great scenes
it just keeps it's just because the
great stuff becomes in a minute for a
made-for-tv movie it's fantastic
honestly yeah made for TV movie it's
amazing yeah it's one of the better
production value of the team if this was
a feeder movie I could see myself having
a little bit more problems with it
I'm a curious about that some things I
feel like almost might have worked
better for me in a theater the first
half when I was watching I was going I
wish this was in the theater I'm kind of
shocked to hear that critics aren't
liking this movie and I'm not shocked to
hear they're not liking it but I'm
shocked to hear that people are bashing
on it that that's what it sounds like
what people are communicating me that
it's a terrible film I could see you if
you don't like it I would understand it
but it's uneven but if you're like it's
terrible not know and I don't think it's
uneven I think there's like a good 15
percent I could do
but I wanted to say it's uneven I guess
it could at very least have done with a
little trimming a little smoothing out
but I don't think there's anything that
they can't improve upon and make more
interesting moving forward to the sequel
I think they'd probably be smart enough
to you know take a little feedback guys
did you see bright did you like it
I mean what's your honest opinion of it
well you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell you
could download the Stardust app and
follow us first at the real rejects link
in the description box and also check
out our patreon it's like a second
youtube channel over there with a lot of
extra exclusive perks